we live in a culture where uh we're not
expect supposed to expect our neighbors
to share values with us we're supposed
to Live and Let Live and he used to love
that phrase when I was younger right
because like these libertarian ideals
and it's not that they don't now but I
think ultimately the fabric of our
society is strong when we have a
understanding of what is is acceptable
and what is not acceptable so the the
some of the stuff he's describing here
right like don't come to my town and
attack law enforcement and we can have
all kinds of debates about law
enforcement but we should all mutually
agree that we expect one another to
preserve our our safety right we don't
want that as a social contract to be
violated uh all of these ideas that he's
promoting are actually completely
reasonable it's just that he is
presenting them in a way that people
don't like and you're not supposed to
tell other people well you're not
supposed to do this this is against what
we're allowed to do we're supposed to
let people Live and Let Live however
they see fit which is just toxic
ultimately